[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in sean salisbury morning
host to the sean
salisbury show on sports talk 790 in
houston all right so what is going on
with desean is he injured or why would
he not be going to green bay
well dan
because the distraction is not playing
and he doesn't want to play for them
right now i asked charles robinson
yesterday i'm sure you guys saw him the
door is still open dan they are going to
visit this while a lot of us have it
dead bolted and slammed shut
but between now and the time the season
starts if the commissioner doesn't come
out if there's no legal implication and
he still
there's no restrictions on playing
they're going to they're going to visit
this and see if deshaun watson some
point in time he probably doesn't need a
lot of reps he knows this offense with
tim kelly so why he's not going is he's
not going to place take him i don't
think he's injured if it was it was
minor dan i think this comes down to
sitting down if deshawn watson decided
between now and then the start of the
season i want to play for the texans
this is where i want to be
if he did that dan for this year
and
that the talk is unless there's some
federal felony indictment on him a
felony indictment that the commissioner
is not going to make a decision anytime
soon on
the the information and the the
commissioner's exempt list so if he can
play and there is no restrictions other
than the optics of the legal stuff why
wouldn't you play him the question is
will desean say yes i'll go all aaron
rodgers on you be talked into playing
and we'll deal with this in january or
february because right now they're not
going to play him but i can tell you
this if he's
uh able to play why the hell wouldn't
you play the best guy instead of have
him in shorts and a t-shirt during the
games on the sideline we know he wants
to get paid
but also how can you put together a
trade proposal if you're one of these
teams let's say you're the eagles you're
the dolphins denver
you don't know when he's available and
it feels like the texans aren't taking
you know any kind of secondary deals
that they want top end top end uh return
on watson and they should man they
should want top in return because
the before the legal stuff kicked in
this is one of the three best assets in
the national football league just was
and he instantly makes your team better
now with that in mind i'm not getting 25
cents or 50 cents on the dollar for him
and the stuff i can control is
communicating with him seeing if he
wants to play dealing with the football
stuff the commissioner and the legal
stuff that's how above their pay grade
so let's see what happens but if you're
the texans you say well listen he's
under contract he's not going anywhere
as long as we got him under contract so
he either wants to play
if he can there's no restrictions or he
doesn't so we'll keep him here and then
we'll watch teams like the giants or the
eagles or the broncos or if the vikings
flounder this year six seven teams get
into the mix and you know this dan the
more that's involved the more draft
picks they're going to get the more
first rounders they're going to get his
value will definitely be higher i don't
think missing a season is going to say
well desean can't play football anymore
so if you're nick casario you're not
just going to give him away and i
wouldn't either you hold the cards
nobody else does right now maybe the nfl
and depending on the legal side but i'm
not giving him away either i don't have
to do anything i covered myself with
tyrod taylor so it's going to be on
desean watson whether he wants to play
or not because somewhere somehow
desperation's the only thing that would
make a team right now dan like if you
got a jalen hurts hurt in pre-season or
you didn't think he could play say oh my
gosh let's just do it because eventually
deshawn watson's gonna play anyway so
let's just take the chance so we can get
through the legal stuff desperation will
be the only way they make a trade right
now
how do you broach the kirk cousins topic
without making it political
are we talking about the the uh
he doesn't want to get the vaccine yeah
dan i i
for me
i understand the side of people saying
as a player
that it's selfish because you got other
people's careers wins and losses on your
shoulders i do get that and if i was a
player i'd probably think the same way
but i also when you step outside and you
how could it not be political dan we've
turned a vaccine into republicans versus
democrats conservative versus liberal
which is crazy because both sides get it
and both sides don't i've always been a
guy that say you should have the choice
but that's different in your personal
lives because your personal life ceases
to exist just by you when you cross the
line and 53 other players an
organization and wins and losses and
their paychecks are on the line it's a
tough decision if kirk cousin doesn't
get vaccinated it's not like i wouldn't
hang around i'm not going to be his
friend if kirk cousins does get
vaccinated it'll tell you that he's
taking more responsibility for the team
but i refuse to tell anybody how to run
their life because i don't know what
their health is or what the downfall is
or the
for their health or what goes on in
their family or their religious beliefs
i can tell you this though you have to
keep in mind that it's more than one
person in mind it's not just you and
your family you're talking about guys
that are relying on their paychecks and
wins and losses and part of that falls
on kirk cousin's shoulder but i'm not
telling him if he should get it or not
that's going to be him and his family to
decide
you're in texas i'm curious how big the
uh dak prescott situation is that this
is a little trickier that this isn't you
know we moved on from the ankle it's not
the shoulder itself
and here they are
contacting the texas rangers staff on
did they face any of these kind of
injuries with some of their pitchers
is this something nothing
oh i'm concerned dan i don't trust when
it comes to pro sports
and
doctors or coaches talking to me about
injuries i don't trust any of them not
that they're trying to hide but i don't
trust any of them telling me and you one
thing and not knowing because first off
you're not going to panic a fan base if
you're really really worried and say man
we're concerned about dak well he's
getting reps and we're watching his reps
anytime it comes to that part of the
body on a quarterback dan of course i'm
concerned especially when he's been out
for this time and hadn't thrown a lot of
balls during his time when he was
rehabbing his uh lower half injury so
yeah i'm concerned and they're reaching
out to others which tells me maybe they
don't know what's happening in-house the
cowboys cannot win
a division without him playing with him
they're going to be one of the five best
offenses in the league as long as health
exists so you're damn right i'm
concerned because the defense is trying
to scramble around and play well and
there's a lot of talk in texas and i
think people think well it's early in
camp we'll pooh-pooh it away he's going
to be okay but when it's talking to that
i think there's deeper i think there's
deeper reason for concern uh for dak
prescott than not because you know how i
feel about him i think he's a hell of a
player but i know damn well that without
him the dallas cowboys become just a
team because he's not just a guy he's
one of the guys
these max contracts for quarterbacks
josh allen just got paid we're waiting
to see what happens with lamar jackson
and baker mayfield but why is it that
josh allen just signed his extension
that means lamar jackson has to make
more and then baker mayfield has to make
more at some point can't you just say
hey
baker you're not you're not
a 42 million a year guy you're just not
we're going to give you 30 five years
for 150 i hope you enjoy it i get like
there has to be some kind of financial
sanity here that baker mayfield is not
better than josh allen or lamar jackson
but if he signs last out of these three
then is he going to make the most out of
this three
dad you're you're exactly right you're
worth the line in the sand of this where
there is financial responsibility listen
up those quarterbacks you just mentioned
the guy who's progressed in every aspect
of this game the most is josh allen
there is no question about it and he has
elevated his play lamar's still working
on his passing game baker's still
putting another back-to-back season
together what happens is the pecking
order danny you know this a lot of times
it's not the best guy it's the timing of
it whether it's stack prescott during
his injury needed to happen and how
desperate your franchise is now listen i
think baker mayfield is going to have a
hell of a year but today if you said
sean who's getting paid more josh allen
deserves more but dan let's say they
wait as the season goes on and mayfield
throws for 4
35 touchdowns eight picks and they win
the division guess who's going to make
that kind of money
baker mayfield is so this is a monster
year and with lamar same way they're
both going to hover in that 40 million
range neither one of them even though
he's got an mvp lamar's game still has
to expand in the passing game but a
dynamic talent baker has elevated the
people in cleveland love him and it
doesn't matter what you and i think it
matters to stefanski in the front office
cleveland love him more than somebody
else does or don't love him as much
you're looking in the next seven eight
nine months
those three guys in that draft are all
going to make 40 plus or in that range
but the key is the season if baker wants
to bypass it's just not automatic
because you're the next guy you get paid
you got to pay the best guy but if baker
has a great season and lamar dan you're
going to be looking at guys that will
hover around josh allen if not more that
150 million guaranteed it's called
playing the most important and the
toughest position in the world right now
in sports and those franchises believe
in the guys and all three of them have
made elevation josh is the best of the
three right now baker not far behind and
obviously the most dynamic talent with
his legs and his ability is lamar uh
jackson
if the chargers and rams were a stock
which one would you buy
oh gosh that's a heck of a question
i i'm so i i think matt stafford is a
sneaky mvp cannon i don't even know if
that's sneaky you're not sneaking
anymore yeah yeah i don't think it's
sneaky because we know he can rip it i
would probably if you tell me short term
stock dan rams
longer term stock i'm going like three
years or more two years more i'm taking
the chargers because i believe herbert
is really really special and they've got
a roster i think the rams have a window
but that window isn't going to stay open
long we've seen it in the seattles and
washington and injuries come into play
this year i'll take the rams two years
from now i'll take the charges so
short-term long-term investments i got
the rams this year because i think that
they are one of the big challengers to
the tampa bay buccaneers um in the nfc
and if stafford's upright the whole
season with sean mcvay he's going to
look around saying i can't believe i'm
on a team that actually has a chance to
win for the first time in his career
every week how many teams do you think
have a legitimate chance to win the
super bowl
legitimate chance uh well we know tampa
bay kansas city buff lower at the top
three for me
i would say anytime russ wilson or aaron
rodgers are your quarterbacks you got a
legitimate shot the best roster
is if the quarterback position settled
in san francisco i love their roster and
when they're healthy and then some
sneaky ones if you want to call them at
the cleveland browns roster in the afc
if baker mayfield plays like we talked
about to get that 42 43 million dollars
the browns will win that division their
roster is stacked but the question is do
they believe it can they believe it can
they take the next step probably dan a
half dozen legitimate because there's
some teams that are on the cusp
while i like seattle i don't know if
they're a super bowl team in law i
mentioned russ wilson green bay's
defense got to continue to elevate i'm
not sure that pittsburgh is back yet
depending on what happens with naji
harris in the run game probably six and
then probably a legitimate four or five
and all of them have one thing in common
the quarterback is a guy who can carry a
team for a month or a month and a half
always great to talk to you bud we'll
talk to you soon
great talking to you thanks for having
me on guy that's uh sean salisbury
former nfl quarterback host of the sean
salisbury show sports talk 790 in
houston